special counsel Robert Herr has finished
his investigation into Joe Biden's
handling of classified documents Fox's
senior National correspondent Kevin Cork
has all the details Kevin what can you
tell us Laura you're right the special
council's probe has concluded and as
expected a report is expected to be made
public at least soon to Congress and
then allegedly parts of it if not most
of it is supposedly going to be made
available for the public to see that
according to the attorney general merri
Garland who said as much in a letter to
Congressional lawmakers today now the
year-long investigation as you know
centered on the improper retention of
classified documents by Mr Biden from
his time as a senator and as a vice
president documents were found at his
Delaware home and at a private office
that he used in between his service in
the OT Administration and becoming
president in 2021 now keep this in mind
the difference is going to be important
and how the doj in collaboration with
the National Archives approached Mr
Trump over the debate about presidential
powers to maintain possession of some
documents compared to how they handled
Mr Biden who was just a vice president
and a senator and couldn't make a
similar argument now it's also important
to note this as well Laura former
president Trump has been accused of
obstruction for resisting turning over
documents in his possession again locked
up at the marago compound while Mr Biden
claims he was very Co operative in the
probe despite having documents at
multiple locations including inside his
garage next to his Corvette a garage
that we saw open with the boxes right
out there in the open uh obviously we
expect to get more details about the
timing of the release of this report
from Bob her uh we don't know when
exactly that'll happen Laura probably
sooner than most people expect and as we
get it of course we'll pass along
details but for now back to you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
Hott interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else